hey folks welcome back to the dark horse
podcast live stream q a
cater day edition caturday that's right
our uh oldest darkest cat has taken the
opportunity to go outside
he's flying the cooper he is not
drinking cream today with us
well it's his loss it is although
frankly i'd rather be outside too yeah
me too yeah we should do this outside at
the moment there's
other people out there being outside
noisy yes um
there is what is that lawn care sounds
like it yeah
leaf blower or something yeah exactly
all right we're going to start with
three questions from episode 72
before going to the discord question and
then launch into the questions from the
last hour
could counter woke culture borrow the
tactics that atheism used to challenge
established religion
well i'm not a huge fan of this idea
because i'm not a huge fan of how the
atheist
played it i think the atheists
botched the job by not acknowledging
that religion was something other than a
mental malfunction i guess i don't know
what the tactics
are either so i think that they they got
they
sort of especially like the new atheism
we might sort of got it wrong but i
don't even know what
what the tactics are that have been used
yeah that's a that's a decent question i
i
yeah i can't speak to it directly i mean
they obviously tried some goofy stuff
like uh defining people who are
post-religion as brights that didn't
exactly catch on
oh i don't remember this you don't
remember this yes it's still a
uh a point of mockery of the
um the new atheists but yeah i
i don't know i mean i think i'm not even
sure what it means because
the right thing to do is to acknowledge
what religion is
clearly from an evolutionary perspective
and then extrapolate carefully to the
idea that
we are somewhere new we are not in the
habitat for which our religious
traditions
are evolved and um
so that i agree with all that i don't
think it gets to the question though and
i think the reason that the question is
not quite tracking for both of us
is that we understand religion to be
an adaptive uh an involved state
and uh we are not the first um
to argue and i think john mccarter's
book must be coming out soon in which he
i think largely in this book is arguing
that this
this vogue stuff is a kind of religion
it is religious thinking
um so you know that that would suggest
that it too
is adaptive you know adaptive does not
mean that it is uh
that it is uh honorable or good um
no you i disagree with that because the
difference between
a a a long-standing religious tradition
which we can say is adaptive and a novel
one which we
have no basis okay good um so in effect
so you didn't i understand where you're
going but you should finish the thought
well the thought is just what we have is
a brand new
religious belief set but it's not a
religious belief set in which we can say
all right it's literally false but it
must be true because
it's lasted because it's lasted all of
seven minutes right
um yeah so anyway yeah i think you know
yep
good um if you want to know what happens
if you apply post-modern thinking to
things that matter the suez canal is as
good a guide at this moment as anything
right it's um
i think that's a non-sequitur no
to the extent i mean i just i i don't
think there's anything actually that
went on in the suez canal that has to do
with postmodernity well i don't think i
don't think there is but i guess my
point is
if we extrapolate from the claims about
merit being a conspiracy against certain
people
and logic being logic math a belief in
two sexes all of these things being um
part of these oppressive structures and
then you say okay well what happens if
we get rid of them
and the answer is sooner or later every
canal gets
plugged every type of expertise you need
gets lost and
that's where you end up okay the
question though
which i think we're not going to end up
answering um
is about whether or not the same tactics
can be used given that the two things
are both religions
and so far um you know given that
religion is religion and also the work
the woke revolution is a kind of
religion and a critical distinction
being
that religions that are established are
de facto
established and so have um have
generations of experience sort of
being themselves and being effective and
that
the newest thing has passed no such test
of time
that said i would be interested to see a
list of
what i imagined to be the tactics um
used and you know to
see okay you know which of these if any
some of these may actually have seemed
you know like a bad idea you know on the
atheists part and would be a bad idea to
apply here like for instance calling
yourselves the chosen people effectively
right um
and some of them may just not translate
and some of them might
so i'd be interested in that list but i
we're not generating the list because i
think we're not aware of exactly what
the tactics
um are imagined to have been yep
next question when a person's
development is deprived of certain
elements in childhood
and the person manifests craving like
behaviors in adulthood towards the
missing element
why aren't these behaviors
self-correcting or eliminating
um not 100 clear what the question is
getting at
i would say say you didn't
get say you lived in a home where sugar
was restricted because your parents
understood that sugar was not
i'm talking about literal craving you
know i i read the question to you
exactly as i got it
right but by invoking something like
sugar sounds like we're talking about
i am interpreting the question in a way
i i know exactly what you know about
what the question says
okay but um so it could it could be any
number of things i'm giving an example
because you said that you weren't sure
what the question meant one
one way to interpret this question is
craving like behaviors in adulthood
towards the missing element
it could be parental love it could be
sugar okay
so you know either of those things would
fit this question
so and the question is why does it not
self-correct
why does the craving result in
over-indulgence yes exactly
which is why i include it here i think
it's a i think it's a
yeah interesting question you know why
why don't
why once uncalibrated is it difficult
to get calibrated at some level um i
think the answer in a general sense is
going to be
that you have to
development is a period in which
calibrations happen if
you leave calibration open so that it is
relatively simple to calibrate
everything as you think it should be
calibrated
much longer forever duration of lifespan
you end up a complete mess the
recalibration problem
ends up um you know you reset this and
you realize that 16 other things were
downstream of it that are now
uncalibrated and so the answer is you're
more of a hazard to yourself
if you have that capacity than if it's
taken offline
and that doesn't mean that there aren't
lots of things that we could realize
you know okay i'm permanently living in
an environment where there's more sugar
that is good for me
and i would love to reduce my taste for
it by 75
right sure that doesn't in and of itself
have a negative consequence
why can't i just find that thing but the
answer is
an infinitely calibratable machine is um
not likely to be viable yeah no and i
think actually that
it's like it's a utopian vision and it's
a utopian vision exactly of the sort
that many of the
again the trans activists are engaging
in like well i'm just
i can just change whatever is real about
me
and by by dent of saying now i'm a thing
now i'm a different thing right
and actually um that level of
calibration isn't
isn't what we do it's not possible yeah
you know in some
in some organisms of some certain types
um you know maybe sometimes but not
not us not mammals yes yeah
do you think next question from final
question from episode 72
do you think there is utility in caring
for house plants why do we do this
does keeping plants provide a meaningful
connection to the natural world
or are my many tropical specimens
specimens
merely simulated nature
um i think there is lots of value in it
i suspect that it is one of
a million different things that
let's put it this way raising house
plants surprisingly hard
right actually you have to be tuned in
to their needs in a way
you know we have downstairs an african
violet
my grandmother used to raise african
violets she did a good job of getting
them flowering
they're very sensitive little creatures
and it's you can over water them
i learned from you that watering so that
the water gets on the leaves has
negative consequences which doesn't make
any sense to me because i think they're
south african but um
uh in any case there will be rain where
they come from so
what is the natural yeah so what the
hell but anyway the point is
the tuning into a creature that
when you screw it up is not a tragedy
right you're killing a house plant is
not a
it's not like you know uh mistreating
your animal
right um but getting
uh accustomed to paying attention to
those signs is one of many ways
to tune into both a non-forgiving
physical
system a system in which feedbacks are
real where there are conservation laws
and also to getting good at the kinds of
skills that you do need for
taking care of animals or children or
yeah other people
yeah it is it gets it's it's practice of
a sort
it brings some green inside um you know
we
we don't have many um we have we have so
much nature around us
that out every window is um these plants
is uh is one of our non-plant um
specimens digging at something at the
moment
looking for attention yes um like all
this talk about plants really has been
miffed
um he's gonna step on my computer to
show me just how he feels about this
um and
i will say too that um
you know the the farther north or south
you live
away from the equator the harder it's
going to be to raise tropical plants
indoors because of the sun regime that
there are just some months of the year
where the plants are not going to be
getting enough although understory
plants are accustomed to
consistently low levels of light but
it's it's just a very very different
environment and
i i've begun to wonder about
some of the things that are particularly
missing for house plants like
wind like you know we know that being
outdoors is healthy for us
and we don't know most of the reasons
for that what is he eating
has found the zip ties yes yes um
so you know having a having plants by a
window that you open occasionally i
think will render them
healthier what i'm just
realizing we're in a predicament where
the cat is in a position to potentially
mess up the live stream and we'll
eliminate that possibility okay sorry
you were saying
yes so he's he's off screen for all of
you you can see his ear i guess but he's
sitting in front of a keyboard that
controls
a lot of things that brett has just
turned off yeah so you were talking
about the
missing phenomena in a plant's existence
like
wind like wind yeah and um i
i think we have a few of the mechanisms
for
humans about the value of being outside
you know like
like many pathogens will not transmit as
easily because of boundary layers and
and and wind uh and the fact of
sunlight having many health benefits
some of which we know but
i suspect there are many more that
simply you know being
outside uh has benefits uh that
that we have not begun to understand
with our typically reductionist science
and
certainly that will be true for plants
as well we imagine them as these much
simpler creatures and in some ways they
are
um but are sort of framing of their
striving as tropisms right like they're
they're phototropic they strive towards
lighter they're gravitropic they grow
away from gravity
is pretty simplistic and while
true while true so far as it goes i
suspect that it obscures a whole lot
more complexity
that um that gardeners really will
understand pretty well
and people who are keeping indoor house
house plants alive will understand to
some degree but within these
very interesting constraints that we've
created for ourselves
um i agree and i'm reminded of
the late george estabrook who
was a mentor of ours a botanist
and he was an advocate for
essentially having house plants that you
take
outside and charge them up over the
summer
and then bring them inside
and they yes there's an animal out there
i want to know if it's an interesting
animal i think it may be
but in any case charging your it's
behind a tree at the moment
charging your plants up outside
and then um bringing them inside and
enjoying them over the winter and
basically you have to get good at so you
know they
they don't you know if you're taking
tropical plants which are many of the
plants that we
like to have um you know they can
tolerate outside conditions you have to
be very careful to make sure that they
are in hospitable conditions and then
you bring them in
and yeah winter even indoors is not
hospitable to them but
you know if you should maintain charges
yeah if you can maintain an equilibrium
um which it's not it's not a perfect
analogy but it's good enough and you
know he
he made it work in michigan right like
he he brought
he took tropical plants outside on his
deck or whatever
yeah into his garden yeah and then would
bring them in in michigan
yeah i'm gonna continue we apparently
have like it's just so beautiful here
today and
winter is finally over and it's going to
get wet again tomorrow so we're super
distracted
no i i'm gonna you also are fully
involved in this uh conversation but
there is a large there's a
dark animal outside and there are
terrestrial
yeah there are not very many things it
could be it could be our cat
although it did not appear to be and
it's not somewhere he goes
so anyway i'm going to keep watching
yeah it might
it might well be him um we might uh we
might encourage
one of the boys to send maddie outside
maddie is our coyote
um our coyote it's not that big it's not
gonna be a danger
okay okay so maddie was going crazy
yesterday thinking that there was
something in the ravine
but then she was barking up trees and i
tried to explain to her in her best
english that
canids don't climb trees but she was not
buying it geez i hope i'm not making an
error but my impression was this animal
was much darker than a coyote and
therefore can't be one and i really do
want to see what it was
okay okay we have diverted keep going
i'll read a question you can you can
listen while you're
looking out the window uh with irshad
manji you
had mentioned that you expected this
this is from the discord server this
week
with irshad manji you mentioned that you
expect collapse to happen as a result of
the corrupt forces in society
can you talk about some specific
possibilities for what that might look
like
do you foresee different collapses for
different systems educational system
energy grid local governance online
platforms
so i did tell the fine person who sends
me these this is a gigantic question
um yeah it is a huge which is no doubt i
have no doubt he knew
yeah um i would say we've got various
different kinds of collapse and
you know you can have an economic
collapse that in which your
basic systems remain online you can have
a
collapse born of the stupid management
of things like
a power grid which is much more fragile
than it needs to be
you can have civilizational collapse as
a result of positive feedbacks
that result in something small
cascading and having a bunch of
different impacts
we are definitely to the extent that we
implement
the um desires
of the woke revolution we are inviting a
rather
serious relatively quick kind of
collapse because
essentially demonizing competence
is going to result in incompetence and
at best our enemies abroad take
advantage of our feebleness
and order is maintained enough to keep
food flowing to the grocery stores
or it results in something you know
unthinkable catastrophic collapse of the
very systems that keep us afloat so
anyway that's on the table
and it's part of why those of us who are
focused on this issue
you know we are sometimes accused of
being overly focused on
woke issues in the culture war but what
culture war we're talking about whether
or not we should be able to actually
accomplish the things that are necessary
in order for us to
feed and house our families right i mean
we're talking about the most
basic functions of a society
and so you know i don't see any culture
where i see uh we either will or will
not be able to do these things yeah i
mean i think that's
um again i'm not sure it's addressing
the question but i do think that's at
the core
it's a core disagreement uh between to
the extent there are two sides the two
sides
um position that you have just
taken um that i also agree with that i
imagine that
most if not all of the people watching
or watching this
agree with which is that framing this is
a culture war is
uh misunderstanding the scope of what is
at stake
um and um
the the other side is saying no
it's about priorities and you've got and
and we inc
and we insist on us right yes we insist
on us and i actually remember
um a a discussion that was a
disagreement that i had with a student
of ours
um years ago obviously um
a young black man um who said
it's not time to talk about climate
change we cannot do that we must solve
all of the racism first
yeah uh and um
you know i pushed back as i did when and
this this is a private conversation this
wasn't happening in front of the whole
class but it happened a few times
and um you know i
just as we expected students to push
back against us when we said things that
didn't sound right to them
um that we also made it clear that they
should expect us to push back um and i
did and i never
i never could get past just that framing
right that framing itself was like the
core belief
yeah which was simply racism exists
therefore it must be the only and not
not
just the foremost really but the only
thing on
on the docket until everything is
resolved to you know and this is
the sticking point of course like to to
someone who hasn't yet been named yet
satisfaction
right right therefore it will never be
fixed therefore it will never be fixed
yeah i mean i think it is clearly
tactical um yeah
and it wasn't in this young man's case
like right he didn't know what he was
doing he was repeating something
in all likelihood that he had heard that
sounded muscular and
clever right but the problem is you know
yes you can
hold the ability to address
you know climate issues hostage
as a matter of gaining leverage and the
point is okay but you're also
then taking responsibility or you should
be and you don't sound like you are
taking responsibility for all of the
harm that will come from that thing that
you're doing
and you know i hate to say it but um
there are a lot of awful things that do
not
jeopardize humanity and
right it seems reasonable and natural to
say
actually all of our priorities ought to
involve a recognition
that there may be things that we find
you know intolerable
but that those things that are literally
intolerable by all of humanity
have a higher priority by their very
nature yeah you know
it's like you know ranked lists are is
racism
right like you know it not only didn't
you
rank the things in order i don't agree
with but the fact that you have anything
but the one thing on the list
is an indicator of white supremacy right
and in fact we have heard
claims analogous to this you know the
idea that you know
nuance is itself you know white
supremacist or something the whole idea
of um anything but my priorities and you
are the
evil i am describing right like okay i
get that move but it's not
legitimate yeah and not even clever at
this point yeah it's something you made
up
and you know yes i'm the king of the
world
is a nifty trick but it's um it's not
acceptable
yep um yep yeah won't fly with the
adults
yep okay let's move into the questions
from this last hour
could we make darkhorse available on
utrion utreon
a platform that neither you know i had
heard of before we can mirror
automatically so it won't burden zach
we're a new video platform built to give
youtube some much needed competition
love you guys and that's from patreon
yeah um zach apparently looked into it
just when he saw the question come in
yeah i think we can't give you a
definitive answer
um we need to know more about it it
seems like uh it would be harmless to do
so and probably wise
to diversify in light of uh what the
major platforms
do um so anyway uh it's
it's an interesting idea be curious if
others have experience with the platform
and whether there's a downside to uh you
know if there were a dozen such
platforms would it make sense
to mirror everywhere or does that
effectively
create a problem and there are i mean
excuse me there are some other platforms
and i just
that that's that's the issue is how many
of these are out there and which one
which ones or one is actually best so
um you know if anyone does have
experience with utreon um
maybe apologies to our wonderful
moderator email darkhorse.moderator
gmail.com and then utron itself can do
so as well if you've got
something more than what you've just
said here to say about your product
my son created a planet and said there's
only one type of camouflage things can
only look like rocks
could this sort of malaria camouflage
evolve perhaps because even if that rock
totally moved you still don't know what
it is
[Music]
um i see no reason to i mean you know
just proof of concept
we could have a planet a rocky planet
in which only a tiny number of things
are camouflaged and they happen to look
like rocks
i don't know how you would design a
planet in which i mean i guess if
everything looked like rocks
then what else is there to look like
right but you know there's only
so i had to read it a couple of times
too and it's there's only one type of
camouflage it's not
everything looks like rocks like
rock-solid rocks and things that are
camouflaged look like rocks but then
there's other things
right okay yeah um yeah i don't see any
obvious reason i mean you know i mean
it precludes camouflage ever being
effective in any landscape that isn't
rocky
right yep so you would never have
camouflage evolve
in any landscape that was sandy or
wildly you know muddy and forested or
something
so i think the question is obviously
there are i can't think of a world in
which you would expect this but could
you construct a world
in which this would be the natural
consequence
um you know i sort of think you could
get there but it would be
a world of a small number of entities
rather than a hugely diverse
world i think that's right i think um it
it i can imagine a world in which it
could be the first type of camouflage
but other types of camouflage would
would quickly evolve
i would think yeah
um i'm now hearing that chemicals can be
considered cis or trans
it seems the woke have already taken
over stem thoughts
so i don't actually know if this is a
tongue-in-cheek question or if this is a
this is a serious question
so i have assumed and i have asserted
i've defended the term cis and trans
because i believed they were borrowing
from chemistry
right so this is about chirality this is
about like handedness of molecules
um no it's not chirality it's about
whether a particular if you have two
hydrogens either
you're right it's not chirality it's
that's left right yeah yeah yeah
you could have them over here right and
you could have them over here so the
description of the atoms is the same but
the organization is different
um so anyway i think you know
cis and trans is fine and i've been uh
attacked wait
where in in which context both as
terminology i think it's fine
you know just as the term evolution is
borrowed from chemistry
for biology i see no reason not to
borrow cis and trans
for sociality
but i have been taken to task multiple
times by those who
resent the idea that cis is anything
that needs a label
and i think this is an error i don't see
any reason not to be generous about the
terminology
oh you and i disagree on this um i i
don't call myself a cis woman i won't
no i'm not interested in playing that
game well i'm not just as i don't
declare my pronouns because they're
obvious i don't think it's necessary
that i
say i'm a cis male in other words if
we're going to have a taxonomy
right there's something yeah you know
just as you don't describe yourself in
any regular sense as
heterosexual right right the point is
there is a term for it when you need
that descriptor
and so i i see cis as viable in that
regard
so cis from the latin um meaning
on this side in reference to place or
time um
as opposed to trans or ultra is the
other
um other alternative in this
etymology online originally only of
place sometimes of time
yeah interesting okay cool
um so on this on this side so you know
it's not it's weird it's not exactly
it's not exactly right for for for
gender
on this side versus on you know opposed
to well no no
i think the idea is i guess it's like
it's you have
you are born with your sex and gender
aligned and in this taxonomy you are one
of them
transitions to the other possibility
yeah okay the other binary possibility
i would point out you would wouldn't yes
i would yes
i appreciate that you do so wait that's
not what i'm looking for there we go
okay um
you both seem like you have really great
memories any advice for those of us with
poor recall and the retention of a steel
sieve
or is that just down to genetic lottery
since we can't upgrade our ram and hard
drive space
so i know you have something to say on
this um i
i will keep track of it yes
as you will and i will keep track of it
for you too because i already know
the the kind of thing you're going to
say here um there's there is a lot to be
said actually and
um yeah there is a there's a ton to be
said here
i highly recommend for instance the
jorge louis borges
um short piece it's a story exactly
called funes the memorials
which is a tale of the
risks of having a prodigious memory um
and
it amounts to effectively um you can't
see the forest for the trees um
and you know he does so in a more
more poetic way he arrives at that but
basically the idea is
you remember absolutely everything and
there's no room there's no gaps left for
you to actually make meaning of the
things that you've remembered and so i
used to
in my programs and i think i think i was
too actually dogmatic about this
um because i saw so much especially in
science so much emphasis placed on
memory and litanies and
lists and such i specifically went the
the other way
and said your memory is not going to
matter here i almost never gave in-class
tests and comparative anatomy
labs being a distinct exception to that
um but um
you know i i was very much more emphatic
about the ability to generate ideas and
to keep track of what the implications
of those ideas were and to sort of have
like a decision tree of like okay if
this then this then this
how far back do i have to go in the
nodes to know you know if
i discover that something's wrong like
where would i have to go from there
that said you can fill out much more
fleshed-out trees
the more you can recall pretty quickly
and your recall might even just be like
oh there's a whole class of things that
i know where to look to find them
as opposed to i now have to know what
all those things are i just i need to
know like the place where i can go to
look for the things
um and you do need memory of course for
um
what to know how to assess
what at first pass makes sense or not
just like that ridiculous croco site
that i showed
in the first hour here the first hour
and a half um that was just confused
about the nature of sexual and asexual
reproduction exactly where it was trying
to describe
that fact um if i if i hadn't already
known some things in that domain i might
have been
you know certainly further confused but
also left to believe that they actually
knew what they were talking about which
they didn't
um so lots more to say there's lots of
magical thinking there
should have been called crocus pocus
totally
yeah yeah why not yeah um yeah i would
say look i don't think almost anything
about this memory stuff is liable to be
genetic in the sense that we tend to
think of
of such terms um yeah i think this has a
lot to do
with reward structures and practice and
what i would say is it is very easy to
practice
memory and the question is are you
motivated to do it
the thing you need to know is that in
order for a memory to stick
to go from short-term memory what did i
say 10 seconds ago
into long-term memory will i be able to
understand or remember what i said
10 seconds ago tomorrow there is some
pattern of checking about whether or not
there's been a reactivation
of the memory and so the reason that you
can't necessarily remember what you had
for breakfast yesterday
is that you don't tend to check in with
what you had for breakfast
after it's done remember if you get sick
exactly you'll remember
very clearly but so you can use this to
game the system
and you can basically take an idea that
you know you won't be able to remember
and you can arrange to revisit it at
some periodicity that you can remember
to re-trigger it right so
if a memory is going to evaporate and
you say actually you know i really need
to remember
um you know the symbol for a particular
element
right and i always forget that one right
well then you can just
force yourself to check in with that
chemical element and get yourself to
recover it and
probably it's best a little bit like
strength training is best
if you're just at the limit of what you
can do rather than well within the range
of what you can do because you're
sending a message about
the significance if you allow the memory
to dissipate
far enough that it is not easy enough it
is not easy for you to recover
then you actually practice the skill of
finding your way back to it and so
you're really practicing all of the
adjacent stuff too and the more you
practice the adjacent stuff the farther
you can get
where there's still something you can
grab onto that helps you remember
um you know where you're headed so yeah
so i mean one thing in that
is like flashcards therefore which can
be useful for
certain things um including the various
video versions
um might be more useful with a longer
periodicity between
attempts um to to follow on what you
were just saying
yeah uh more periodicity great if
there's a sleep period
in between different episodes parts yeah
part of why cramming doesn't work nearly
as well
yep um and so but i guess um i thought
you were maybe going to talk about
names and um and the classroom so
um heather and i were just talking about
this i can't remember exactly why
although i will
i will get back to it but um we were
talking about the question
oh we were talking about the question of
how easy it is and how different people
have different facility with remembering
names and i find
i have gotten very very good at this but
i was not very good at this
um i was i would say average at the
point that i started teaching at
evergreen and because
of the way evergreen was structured
where your students were your students
full time
for at least a quarter sometimes three
quarters in a row
and that meant that the really cool
rewarding part of the job involved
knowing everybody individually
um it seemed to me absolutely essential
that you know their names and be able to
interact with them personally
and so i set about you know my little
task for myself
was if i had if i was teaching a loan i
therefore had
25 students and i would typically let in
a few off the waitlist so it might be 30
students
could i have a discussion with them on
the first day where by the end of the
first day i could name them all
and then i would joke with them that i
wanted them all to continue to wear the
same
clothes for the rest of the quarter to
sit in the same seats
right because you'll lose half of them
yeah before the next day but that's not
bad to get half of this
that's amazing one day i i always my
goal was always by the end of the first
week but first day is
that stuff it's tough i mean and 25 like
if you're teaching with someone you got
50
right three-person program 75 like but
still end of the first week for me was
always
like like that will happen and i still
cannot to this day believe that i
actually had faculty at that school
argued to me that it was ridiculous to
try to learn students names
at that school where the so much of the
point was about relationship
right you would you would expect
everybody would be on board and it's
amazing how hard to sell it was
yeah i also started as you know um
requiring
students to learn each other's names
because the community is much better
and this of course mortified a lot of
students because they weren't good at
learning names because
nobody ever forced them to do it um so
you know i'd give them a
deadline by two weeks in every should
know everybody's name
in the room and you know you did some
games didn't you like
throwing names back and forth like send
me a circle and yep like i'm gonna look
at you and name you and then you have to
look at someone else and name them that
sort of thing
right yeah and you know typically on the
first day i would have
some exercise in which we were talking
about some part of the content that was
going to get us into whatever we were
studying that term
but i would you know have people
contribute
i would pick up their names and then at
some point i would say all right who can
name
everybody in the room and the thing is
almost nobody was any good at it but
usually in a class of 25 or 30
people there'd be one or two aces who
were really good at this
for whatever reason i never knew why
yeah but they were able to do
you know the same thing right away um so
anyway there's
variation i think it's developmental i'd
be super curious
um if those people were reliably aces at
other types of things
as well um you know one one thing that
does right away is like those
two people or whatever are now known
it's like oh they're like i know i can
always ask them
about what her name is you know and when
it comes time to oh
god we're in a group with five other
people and i don't know two of their
names like who does
right yeah totally useful to have that
they did tend to be
people uh with a diverse skill set
um they were often they were often ace
students and
uh often they may not have even really
realized that they had this special
skill but they did realize at the end of
the first exercise that they knew
everybody's
name and yeah interesting yeah it was it
was interesting
so again i'm not totally sure we uh
any advice you know if yeah okay what's
the advice
the advice is work on it uh yeah the
advice is set yourself
tasks and you know the trick is
when you fail the task don't dwell on it
that's not the point the point is for
you to set the task and to figure out
how it is that you can actually get your
brain
to do this thing and once you figure it
out figuring out how to get better is
easy
okay so i would say give yourself
challenges and then try to meet them
next question how do forensic analysts
figure
out that ancient life forms died from
soft causes like disease or drowning if
the murder weapon can disappear
as opposed to things like bite marks or
bone damage that leave a hard trace
behind
did they send this to the right podcast
yeah yeah i don't i
you know i i know a little bit about
um how some how some diseases actually
leave traces in bone that's not
um that's not super clear i'm talking
can you tell from the question fossil or
sub fossil
ancient ancient so the distinction well
a murder weapon
oh murder is ancient so there's
definitely
true um so the distinction is sub fossil
which is
so i guess i would say like does because
disease will leave something systemic
like you know something like bite mark
or bone damage you know like
you've got acute versus chronic sort of
reveal in the skeleton
and um although it's rare sorry i
interrupt you i know but like
it's rare to find a whole skeleton but
even if you have just like one long bone
or even just a couple of pieces of bone
if you've you know if you find a
a mark cool you got a mark and absent
any other evidence you might assume that
that was the cause of death
but if you find like modeling or
porosity
or something throughout you've got
something systemic that um you know is
probably attributable to like a class of
diseases rather than a particular
particular disease yep um i was just
going to say
sub-fossil uh the bone is still present
and so there's a whole host of the bone
yeah it's still present yeah also in
so the actual bone you're talking about
like the actual actual
the bone has been replaced by other
minerals so it's actually stone but you
can see the shape of the bones yeah that
was present
in sub fossil the bone is still present
and so there's chemical analysis that
can be done
and you could get information that way
yeah
um you know obviously the more recent
the death the
more reliable that information is but
right you're at 49.
okay we're going to do a few more from
last hour
what do we do with the hijacked term
anti-racist surrender it to people like
kendy put in snarky finger quotes and
hope it takes on the same connotation as
democratic people's republic of korea
or fight to reclaim it um
yeah so far i use snarky finger quotes
but i'm not pleased with that solution
right um i think what we need to do is
found the anti-anti-anti-anti-racism
movement did i get the right number
i don't know okay um or we could start
referring to the anti-racist people's
republic of korea
um yeah i don't know i mean you know
general answer is yes we need to have a
sense of humor about this stuff
um and the fact that the movement is so
damn humorless
is uh it's an opportunity for us to um
to tell more fun yes it is a tell yeah
it does not suggest
depth of thought that's right because
humor tends to go along with depth of
thought
yeah but yeah somewhere in there okay
here we have a devil's advocate uh
position
from last podcast i can imagine candy
saying something like your comparison of
humans to dogs is clear evidence of your
racism
and reason enough not to waste my time
or debating an obvious bigot
how would you rebut this um
dr candy it's not clear that i can rebut
it so i would like you to level that
charge on the dark horse podcast so that
we can talk about it like adults
good done dating in college has been
difficult for many young men in my
generation
most of the women at my university are
anti-racist should a prospective
partner's audiology be a deal-breaker if
the goal is a long-term relationship
i think if it can be described as an
ideology as opposed to
a belief system that they are thinking
about tinkering with it's going to be
harder to change
on the other hand ideologies you know
people people do change their ideologies
anyone who is proud to have an ideology
is going to be resistant to change
because ideology is inherently resistant
to change
it's not about questioning what is
happening
underneath you know behind the curtain
well i don't
pretend to know how this works on the
ground for young people these days
but in some sense if you can
use the question of somebody's reaction
to this um as a litmus test without
destroying your credibility or your
social your ability to navigate socially
then they're in effect doing you a favor
right because anybody
who runs screaming at the
statement of obviously true things my
guess is
not really long-term partner material
right just really not and i would
say long before woke was uh
a force in this landscape i used to
advise
students regularly um don't ever
sign up for a long-term relationship
with somebody who doesn't have a sense
of humor about themself
so anyway i guess my point would be
um to the extent that somebody can't
tolerate
uh reason i'm not saying they have to
agree with you but to the extent that
your disagreement over obviously
your adoption of obviously reasonable
conclusions
is a deal breaker for them they're doing
you a favor
uh someone says we need more much more
of the gain of function possible leak
thank you so yep we're keep beating that
drum
um if i i don't know this
this so i'll just redo what we got here
virologist stanley perlman
was quoted in a bloomberg article that
serial passage would weaken a virus
if done in the absence of antibodies and
t cells
and he has not seen virulence go up in a
lab what are your thoughts
with regard to gain of function um
i'd like to see um i'd like to see the
article um
yeah so for one thing i can't quite even
if this is
even if this is accurate in a narrow
sense
uh if you were to serially passage in
humanized mice or
ferrets which are both highly likely
serial passage environments then that
doesn't apply because they both do have
immune systems so
um i guess maybe that's it it's like
it's
we're talking about in in vitro serial
passaging somehow if it's absent
antibodies and tissues in tissues yeah
um but it's like most of the serial
passaging that i
am fatally aware of is in in vitro in
which case of course it has antibodies
and t
cells so in vivo i mean i mean in vivo
yes thank you
um so like i i just don't know what this
i don't i've never heard of him before
and i don't know what his lab situation
is
i mean in a technical sense there will
be some truth to it
how significant is the truth
right if you were to do this in vitro
then effectively whatever constraint is
placed on the virus
by the immune system is absent
however it's not clear to me that the
implications of that are
dire in the short term because we're
really talking about a system
by dire you mean lowering of virulence i
don't know what dynamics
for the uh virus right so
his claim is that you would weaken the
virus by
eliminating selection for dodging the
immune system
right that the virus would then become
very susceptible to the immune system
yeah
so i mean and that that claim therefore
is that all serial passaging
without he has not specified in vitro
well he has not specified that we are we
are taking what we're seeing in this
question to
be specifically about in vitro serial
passaging but he is basically saying
you know and it sounds a little bit like
little magic arm waving stuff
um that all cereal passaging is going to
um
produce a weakening of a virus
a reduction in virulence which
i i just don't know this to be true well
no and
the point is you've got different
tensions to the extent that what he is
saying
is reasonable there is one constraint
that you are eliminating which is then
going to be reintroduced at the point
that you have a virus
in the wild that's the immune system it
is not clear that the implication is
substantial of that
right i don't know i would not predict
it is substantial because the nature of
the immune system is a
self-non-self-recognition system
and so right but the i mean i think if
i'm i'm trying to um
like steel man an argument that i'm not
even sure i totally have all the details
on and understand fully
i think the argument that i'm imagining
he's making
pearlman is that if you do in vitro
serial passaging
and there and without antibodies and t
cells and
therefore you don't get an increase in
virulence by the time it does
enter another an actual host something
with antibodies and t
cells the clock was basically stopped
for all that time so it's like it's
re-entered
it's like it's entered a host for the
first time at the point that has indeed
entered a house for the first time or
gone in vivo serial passaging
well i didn't 100 follow that um i
do my phone is back there making noise
um i do uh
i mean i think we're i think we are
saying the same thing i'm not 100 sure
we're saying the same thing
how much actual material implication is
there for the absence of this constraint
right if it reverts a tiny fraction of
its accumulated wisdom over a thousand
years
there may be no detectable difference
and so
um unclear to me
it's just unclear to me whether this is
a relevant critique or a pure
red herring yeah yep i agree
another another serious question if the
sars cov2 virus jumped to the minor
if the sarsko v2 virus jumped to the
miners
happened in 2012 and that is eight years
ago which seems like a long enough time
for the virus to become efficient at
human to human transmission no
totally but there's no evidence that it
was in the population
exactly so it did go to the miners it
killed three three of six
right uh and then what happened to the
other three they recovered
they were covered and there's no
evidence that they transmitted it to
anyone else
right there ever ever they didn't
transmit it to each other either as far
as we know
they all got it from a bat or bat from
the cave yeah
um okay one more question and then we
will go to the
to this hour's questions uh the swedish
swedish
i was just gonna say that i'm about to
mispronounce the swedish name but
instead i mispronounced swedish yes you
did
the swedish lucible bun with saffron
is only available traditionally in
november and december really
love this fantastic yeah imagine that
imagine that very cool november and
december
when you might imagine that you wanted
to interfere with the reuptake of
serotonin
yes by virtue of the darkening of the uh
the days yes
okay it's almost too good it's almost
too good um
first question in the next hour if one
by trans is sacred
is two by trans sacred squared
trans yes y or single transition
activists oppressing the
multi-transition minorities in their
minority
yes totally exactly right totally yes
um so i actually i think i ended up
tweeting this
was going to suggest that instead of
calling it de-transitioning
they call it re-transition
re-transitioning right
or double-transitioning which would make
it extra trans
and therefore i don't know or
given the apparent latin here ultratrans
ultra trans totally
[Music]
i don't know what this means evaluate rk
selected memes
do you enjoy busking
hold on that seems like two different
things yeah
i can't make the connection do you enjoy
busking brett
i've not actually tried it as often as
you might imagine
no i i have not either um not
you know not being able to carry a piano
around i guess was one of the right
of the things that got in my way i bust
an occasional move but
i just i don't know yeah it's not that
we have no subway
here oh that's what's limiting you well
i don't know something is certainly
limiting me and i was just
you think it's the lack of a subway yeah
does philadelphia have a subway
does philadelphia have a subway i should
really know if philadelphia has a subway
i think it does have a subway and you
lived in philly for two years i did
there is no
the problem is that i was hanging out
with a lot of new yorkers and they
definitely have a subway so i was on a
certain number of subways in that time
and mario basque well that was
then yeah
the only place social credit wouldn't
work is in the u.s
it might work swimmingly well with for
china russia and iran have a monoculture
so is this cultural revolution specific
to the west only
right could you go back to the beginning
of that question yeah i think it's
i think we're talking about like woke
social credit um
wait no i don't actually know the only
place social credit wouldn't work is in
the u.s
it might work swimmingly well for china
russia and iran who have a monoculture
so is this cultural revolution specific
to the west only
i feel like the actual question doesn't
totally proceed from the
from the statement yeah i'm not sure
what what this person is getting at
um i think the problem is social credit
could potentially
work anywhere but work to do what is the
problem
um and so you know a market
is a de facto social credit mechanism
it does accomplish certain things some
of them
horrifying many of them awesome and the
real trick
is instead of doing some top-down
authoritarian social credit system
to fix the market so that what it
accomplishes is actually desirable and i
really think that that's the sum total
doesn't make it easy i'm not arguing we
know what it is that would make it
awesome
but i am arguing that the um
most effective least awful solution
will be a market that is targeted at
problems that markets are good at
solving and therefore
results in the well-being the increase
in well-being for those who
create things that are good for us yep
right that's what we should want and we
should not
piss and moan about the fact that some
people will live better than others
nobody should live terribly if they play
by the rules but
to have people who bring something
valuable to planet earth that's good for
us
we should uh get used to the idea that
that should result in them being
disproportionately
rewarded and therefore equity is
nonsense
right you don't want equal outcomes
right no
no you don't unless you know you will
lose
otherwise well that's that in some sense
this is the question
is given that we shouldn't want equal
outcomes because they are inherently
unjust will you always have that
fraction
which happens to be losing from
a system of rewards rebelling against
the system of rewards in favor of an
equal outcome system
yep um and then i should just say
that none of that is to say that our
system
rewards people correctly right which i
don't think it does
right but that doesn't mean you don't
want a system that rewards people yes
um what is your take on colloidal silver
used for antimicrobial treatment
for intestinal sanitation what about its
different uses inhaled or implied on
skin
gargled ingested what about using it for
children
thanks and be well i have no idea i've
never looked into it
it's you know
it looks some some combination of
woo-woo and crackpot but it might it
might not be
i mean i think the problem is it has no
historical
analog that i'm aware of and therefore
you're
signing up for unknown consequences so i
guess my
instinct is it's it is
dangerous in the same sense that a
vaccine about which you know nothing of
its long-term
consequences is dangerous which doesn't
mean it's harmful yeah may or may not be
but it's risky yep
hi someone wants to go outside yes
uh will cnn get deep platform for coba
disinformation the way all the little
people talking about lab leak did in the
past
gee i wonder that's a good point
yeah variation of the fermi paradox if
complex life was abundant in the comma
cosmos shouldn't we expect to see macro
organisms that eventually evolved for
life in space
seems like one hell of a niche yeah i
think i mean i think that is the
fermi paradox oh evolve for life in
space yeah
life in space is tough i mean there's
photons
if you're close enough to a star
but what do you do with them i mean yeah
are these this is the question really
about living
in space yeah no i if it's just about
living in space
then um you know once you once
organisms that evolve on planets get to
space and they can evolve to be better
adapted to space but
like life evolved evolved for
life in space there's nothing you
already have to have the technology in
order to i mean there's nothing there
there's no there's no there
maybe the question is about would you
find species
adapting to interstellar travel yeah
that was my first that was the first
interpretation yeah okay you absolutely
would you would as long as there was
reproduction
post travel right if you had uh yeah
planet colonizing species right then
all of the downstream planets would be
increasingly well adapted to the
transition that gets you between planets
right
exactly um
have you heard about abigail schreier's
book irreversible i think it's not
irreversible change i think it's
irreversible damage
uh the transgender crazy yeah this
the title here is wrong i believe it is
irreversible damage the transgender cray
is seducing our daughters
um she went on jordan's pod jordan
peterson's podcast
um yeah i actu i talked to her when she
was writing the book actually um i think
she quotes me in it
um it's terrific and it's much shorter
than she wanted it to be
and it's still extraordinary and she's
very important and in fact we mentioned
her
in the last hour yep um
i'm not sure what this person is
responding to i'm hesitant to take it if
this stuff is so great why isn't the why
aren't the parent companies transparent
with their
science the small pattern that doesn't
seem like
that's the main question yeah the small
box the small box vaccine was question
mark
um um yes i mean we we definitely want
transparency
and there's you know there's a tension
between intellectual property and not
having
information stolen by your competitors
and having information available
to the people who would be your
customers but um
but that slider is way over towards
protecting
companies intellectual property at the
moment
in a discussion with a silicon valley
executive
he insists that the coveted lobby
hypothesis is impossible and a
conspiracy
how does one even discuss it
um i do think i did i come up with the
right name ultimately that it was the
nicholson baker article
in the like the new york post
intelligence or maybe in december of
2020.
i should i can pull it up but i do think
that that article maybe more than
anything else like you know we've
certainly had conversations but in terms
of just being like not
forcing for many people being told they
need to watch a video
is a barrier and for some people it's
the opposite it's you know being told to
breed a thing is a barrier but
my guess is if it's a silicon valley
exact just being like this was published
like that that has struck me and there's
also plenty of actual
scientific literature yeah but that's
that's a harder in
as well so i'm just going to look this
up yeah i would also i have not
i have skimmed it i have not thoroughly
read it yet but i would also
point to rosanna segreto
and yuri degen and they have a third
co-author who i'm forgetting
at the moment but they have just
published a paper looking at the
evidence it's basically a review article
that looks at the evidence
on these things and it is excellent for
understanding
you know in sober scientific language
what is being
discussed and why and you know yeah
anybody who thinks
that this is a simple matter of a
quote-unquote conspiracy theory is
either
lying or has looked into it not at all
because
obviously it's a viable hypothesis
um so i don't i would love to be able to
show that brett but i don't have that
paper
is it this one it's not this one is it
hold on is it bio essays yeah
this is the one okay
pretty sure oh but this is just two this
is just too authored
um well here you keep going okay so
zach if you can you can show my screen
for a minute um just an answer to this
question answer to people
um you know what what you might show so
there's um
and this is an academic this is a
scientific article and bio essays
published
um actually it looks like late 2020
many authors the genetic structure of
sars kobe 2 does not rule out a
laboratory or
origin this is by the two authors that
brett already mentioned rosanna secreto
and
yuri um degan thank you degan i never
get the pronunciation right
um and then for a non
um hey zach can you show me screen
please thank you
for a non-uh scientific article
this piece long nicholson baker more
narrative and style
published oh actually it looks like the
very beginning of january of this year
on the lab lake hypothesis um and uh
very compelling it got it got the ire up
of a lot of the right people
yeah yeah it's a it's a quite a good
article um
yeah so anyway i have uh
this article here which we can't show i
think it's the one that you found but
it's many authored
no it's all it's quite a different
article actually um so i can try to find
that
um you you're not showing it in a way
that anyone on screen can see that yeah
well i don't know how useful that's
gonna be um you wanna just tell me the
title
uh it is should we discount the
laboratory origin of covid19
and it is in environmental chemistry
letters i don't see it yet
okay i think we should move on yep and
that that just came out
just came out it's quite good i was the
first author and a bunch of other
authors
all right so
maddie's desperate to go outside um
so i there are a lot of things to be
done about discussing it
actually but i think sharing some
resources is is a good
first approach um 73 i've watched them
all and had a blast my question is
simple
do you get enough income from the dark
horse podcast and extras to be
financially secure if so
great if not what should we do hmm yeah
i got this one that's a nice question
um we're doing fine
what we don't have is security and this
is the thing
that's very troubling about our
situation is having been
uh forced out of jobs that we thought
were quite secure
we now are making a living where our
living
is dependent on let's say youtube
continuing to allow us to do the dark
horse podcast
i at some point want to talk about the
evidence
that youtube is not being even-handed
about this and that in fact
there is a thumb on the scale that is
causing
the dark horse podcast not to reach many
people who would like it
but let's just say it is insecure to
live in an environment where everything
we do depends on uh
corporations that can be pressured
publishers
video platforms twitter and so
anyway yeah security is not something we
have figured out nor
does it appear that there's any obvious
way to um
to get there from where we are what can
you do
i would say in addition to supporting us
if you can the number one thing that i
think people could do
is circulate material from darkhorse so
that it reaches more people because what
i feel the thumb on the scale
has to do with the popularity of the
podcast
growing but it's exposure not growing
right we can see this in the numbers
right so you would imagine if the
if the podcast was less appealing to
people over time you might see the
numbers
slow but we see the opposite we see a
lot of enthusiasm
and what we don't see is the numbers
growing in fact they slowed to a trickle
at like almost a point and so that feels
like
an algorithmic um
distortion and the way to overcome it is
to use whatever
influence you have to point people to
things you think that they might
be interested in seeing yeah share share
it yep and um
and that's part of why we have the clips
channel because um our terrific clips
guy really does clip out
pieces um by and large we actually don't
make the decisions he clips what he
thinks is right and if if people think
that there's something specific that
should be clipped
they should email our
darkhorse.moderategmail.com and
uh they will pass it on to um the clip
sky
um but those clips are often a way for
people to get in
right to start seeing new conversations
across a wide variety
of of topics that are
unified by you know respect for
you know people and ideas and not being
denigrating
just because you disagree with someone
um i will say you know we are
we don't particularly you know we're not
interested in
the commerce aspect of this but we have
merchandise now and we're you know we're
pleased with the merchandise we have
like all of these things are attempts to
diversify so that if something does fail
um we have other we have other roots
right thanks for asking the question
though appreciate it
um i feel uneasy about taking these
vaccines
but some of my friends have got it
already they're very pro-vaccine and are
starting to ask why i haven't taken it
yet
how would you navigate this
um presumably you are um
eligible at this point i'll student be
asking yeah i mean i
i think it's it's tough because this has
become a moral issue
and the moral issue
obscures the analytical issue right and
you know in the
best of possible circumstances there
would be a moral issue you don't want
people uh if the vaccines were truly
as safe as could be arranged
right if we had high levels of uh
certainty about their consequences
then everybody should take their fair
share of the risk but
um the problem is we are not getting a
straight story we're effectively being
told that they are safe when nobody
could possibly know that
which means that we are all left to our
own devices to figure out
how much danger there might be and
um the uh
nobody can force you or maybe they will
ultimately force us but morally speaking
they shouldn't be able to force you to
take a vaccine if they're not being
honest with you about
the safety profile um
so anyway i've sort of lost my train of
thought in the dog
leaving but
okay there's no good there's no good way
to to deal with it because
there is this implication that those who
opt out are
are not sure are not shouldering their
part of
the burden when in fact we have not been
told the
the proper story which is that we are
taking unknown risks and that we ought
to look at them very differently based
on how old we are whether or not we've
already had covet
all sorts of things and these the
discussion is just not mature enough
that we can get to the question of all
right what share of the risk really
belongs to you
yeah that's right uh just a note of
appreciation bretton heather podcats and
dogs for your great energy and
conversations much love from scotland
johnny thank you thanks johnny is
fragile memory in the sense that it can
be tampered with advertently or
inadvertently
adaptive
um i'm not sure what fragile memory
refers to yeah i don't i don't know if
that's a term of
a technical term i've never heard it
before if it is um but
certainly the ability to to deceive
yourself
to be deceived such that um your actual
motives are obscure even to yourself
uh can be adaptive there's an
explorative exploration of that by
our first mentor bob trivers um
the adaptive value of deceit and
self-deception but beyond that i'm not
sure
well i would say there is reason
different people
could have different roles in society
that would have them
be more or less plastic in this regard
you know forgetting is an adaptive
phenomenon and it could be that certain
things that you would want to do would
uh cause you to forget at a higher rate
and to do so productively um my guess is
we're
botching the job and we just have random
um developmental phenomenon that cause
an arbitrary distribution of
our capacity to remember things but
yes you could certainly imagine a
situation in which different people had
different capacities in this regard and
that it was valuable that it be that way
i agree good um
and i'm not sure what that
means um are we experiencing a war on
america be it cultural international etc
or on the open internet
that allows thought to work outside of
popular institutional influence
like the media or university
um again that sort of seems like two
separate
ideas are we experiencing a war is
somebody inflicting something on us
um and then there is something about
thought
existing outside of the mainstream the
clearly thought is
flourishing outside of the mainstream i
think uh eric makes the point frequently
about the dysfunction being about
institutions yep i think he's right
about this
and that there's lots of
non-dysfunctional stuff happening but
it's all
extra institutional yeah and then that's
a separate question from whether or not
the somebody is um
seeding the psychosis that is causing us
to tear ourselves apart
and it's a different question i don't
know of any evidence of that but i i
certainly wouldn't rule it out
yep i agree uh so for some of the
super chat is doing something weird here
the the
spreadsheet into which it's been dumped
um so i missed at least one question
here which
i will go back to the one that i see as
we are not sure of the long-term effects
of the mrna technology do you think it's
wise even being less effective to opt
for j and j
which do you see that they've rebranded
they're actually now calling themselves
j and j not johnny
johnson anymore oh man they're having
their kfc moment
um anyway um opinions of the long-term
safety of mrna technology so you know
we've done
i think it was i think it was episode 58
where we spent just a ton of time on
vaccines and
um you know basically um
yes in um well
we should be careful knowing nothing
about the long term
which would you guess is more exactly
dangerous
that's a relatively easy question i
think doesn't mean that you won't find
that the j
j dna vaccine is more
harmful but the question is which runs a
greater
risk of being harmful so those are two
very different things and the last thing
we want is responsibility for
whichever one turns out to be more
dangerous long-term
or more harmful you said it was going to
be the other therefore your model is no
good
it's a question of ex-ante versus
ex-post
good decision making and this is a tough
call
because um yes there are extra there's
extra novelty
in the rna vaccines that extra novelty
runs extra risk which doesn't mean that
the harm will end up being there but if
i had to bet
that's how i bet yep and the j j vaccine
also has novelty
and you know i'd rather than any of
those a traditional vaccine
yep
see where were we my mother was
diagnosed with covid last week
we asked to have the blood test to
confirm but the doctor refused several
times
stating they only ordered that if the
quick test came back negative
also i asked what we could take if we
started symptoms
over the counter meds etc any thoughts
so i don't know why they wouldn't do the
blood test
uh that seems that seems like a mistake
um that seems like an obvious mistake
um but then in terms of um
symptoms um
vitamin d vitamin d hyphen activity
seems
well vitamin d carries very little
risk and potentially very big upside
ivermectin
using it off label um i would say the
evidence
is pretty strong but the evidence is not
conclusive and so you're taking a risk
by taking a drug that hasn't been
prescribed
and isn't being prescribed for
for this condition probably where you
are
yeah there are there are places i can't
remember now but we have been sent
links to various protocols in various
hospitals where ivermectin is very much
part of the treatment protocol
but it's not universal it's not
universal and what i you know
do your own research um i do have a
couple papers
i will see if i can dig them up maybe we
can put them in the notes but
um you want to get the dosage right
we're talking about mechanics and
you know you want to be careful about
things like side effects but it does
seem to be
a good and effective drug in this case
and uh yeah let's put it this way
we can't really advise you to take it
because you're you and
we're not doctors or any doctor anyone's
doctor not anyone's doctor yeah
however if i was in the situation of
having come down with covet i would take
it
yep um and you know vitamin d is just a
supplement
that you can buy and um frankly if
you're
sick but not too sick to get out of bed
and it's warm enough be outside
and you know i don't know i haven't seen
nothing about that actually helping in
the case of
um being sick with kovid but there's
some remarkable evidence gosh i think we
may have talked about this in the very
first live stream actually
a year ago um that tuberculosis wards
the outcomes are better if um you open
windows such that you get a cross breeze
and that patients do better
yet if you take them outside and if you
just let them
um get better outside and you know what
what all is it again is it just the sun
is it also the wind
is it the about the boundary layers and
them not being so densely afflicted with
the pathogen
some combination of that plus other
things we haven't named yet probably
could also be that a tuberculosis ward
is effectively a serial passage
experiment and that we don't realize it
because you've got a bunch of people
who are afflicted with nominally the
same condition but there will be
you know mutations and things and so
imagine so you don't just have tb
like you've actually had tb four times
and it's four different strains
you've got every strain in this room
yeah you know
so amazing yeah
um on the anniversary here is money for
the mods annual box of romantic
chocolates
also brett get a bolo tie for [ __ ]
sake
hell yeah you're not getting a boy why
am i getting ebola i don't know okay
he wants you too i will look into it i
doubt i didn't i didn't say he's not
getting one because
i'm saying he can't but i just know you
well enough that i really don't think
you're gonna end can i get an
electronic one an ebola time
i don't know it's getting late it is it
is okay
um what time are you backsack i'm here
okay okay
um let's do like three or four more here
the rapport between you two is endearing
would that we all could be so lucky i
think i actually get better at having
contentious conversations without
creating interpersonal issues just
watching
hell yeah that's awesome that is a large
part of the point that's great
thank you why do children seem to be
less susceptible to covet
my kids get colds and other viruses all
the time so why not covet
do you need to have a more evolved
immune system or have past adolescence
yeah you know what be useful to begin to
answer this question is if we had a real
firm foundation of like what the origins
were of this virus because that would
help
us understand a lot more about what the
evolutionary pressures had been on it
before
it became a pandemic worldwide um but
apparently we're not allowed to ask
questions like that are we
yeah well the i wonder
actually and this goes very much to your
point
the rubric we discussed last time in
light of
the argument of
against using this type of vaccine mid
pandemic
was yes the model there was effectively
that kovid is fended off
by the non-specific community
right and the specific community
separately and that basically as you
grow
older your non-specific immunity
fails as a result of senescence it grows
weaker
and your specific immunity grows
stronger by virtue of the fact that it
is informed
of things in your environment and so so
just to be clear about
names non-specific and specific immunity
also goes by innate and adaptive
immunity yeah those are the same
innate immunity you're born with an
adaptive immunity you acquire
and vaccines acquire it in
cases where you haven't encountered the
thing but in any case
if you imagine that the innate immunity
when it is strong is very effective um
but as it grows weaker you grow
vulnerable
and then the question is so as you age
you get more vulnerable to covid
both at the level of did it infect you
and having infected you did it jump to a
lot of tissues and make you very sick
then that would explain that would
explain the distinction
and uh so it is at least consistent with
that model yep
exactly right
um
is it possible these live streams are in
fact intellectual and moral busking
yes um they're not as musical as they
might be
but they are they are moral and
intellectual
i mean more often than not
okay uh we just got four more and then
we're then we then we cleared this one
out here all right
100 barges and four tower cranes unload
the boat and we're done
i don't know if that's right but that
doesn't sound as complicated as it might
be
we're talking about the suez canal yeah
oh i know what we're talking about 100
barges and four tower cranes
unload the boat and we're done one so
by the way i'm i'm unable to talk on
this topic because i did have so much
inadvertent exposure to the panama canal
yeah and so i'm thinking there was yeah
remember the two cranes
that lived in the panama canal goliath
and i don't remember what the name of
the other one was they literally named
one of the cranes goliath
yeah and it deserved the title too it
was a gigantic
barge with a huge so it was by the locks
or it was
like the time it moved around though and
in fact there's a great story
um i don't know i can't remember i think
it was uh
it might be 2020 the news program did an
expose
on the disappearance of the goliath
crane as if it was some scandal and in
fact it had not disappeared or something
um
but we're off topic
that is my recollection of the story
from when i was there but
in any case the thing is these
containers are huge these containers
are you know we see them on the highway
yeah they're semi-truck
trailers and
moving i'm just imagining
look i do think it's probably the right
thing to do i'm questioning
how much uh it would take
and those numbers sound low to me but
maybe this person is proceeding from
information that they actually have
right um so i don't know
yeah if it were me i'd start unloading
it because uh
you know the sooner the better really
yeah yeah um
speaking of algorithm i can't speak
either
speaking of algorithmic distortion how
would you explain the like dislike
ratios of just about all biden-era white
house videos
i don't have any idea what the like
dislike ratios are yeah so i wouldn't
explain them because i don't know what
they are
yeah i don't know what they are either
yeah i have a guess but i'm not going to
guess out loud because
wait i want to go back to the barge
question okay
it's the wrong way why what do you need
more cranes and fewer barges
no no no i think no that's nice oh it's
the right you don't unload the boat what
do you do
you do unload them you sink the boat
that's what you're gonna argue
good great atomize the boat no
uh here's what you do okay um
chinook helicopters it's
more powerful than chinook salmon yes
absolutely um chinook helicopters yeah
you
unload the boat to the shore
so you don't a chinook can lift a loaded
i think so that's the trailer container
that's the purpose of that thing
the chinook well not that particular
thing but the purpose
of what the purpose of the the double
rotored helicopter is heavy lifting
oh okay i didn't know that um so and
it's not the only one there are others
now but
anyway are there helicopters large
enough to lift
these containers i believe there are if
there are
then we need to get several of them and
they need to offload the containers to a
adjacent location at which point they
can be
moved at will once you've uh
emptied the ship once the cabbage has
gone through
once the cabbage has dislodged the
obstruction
right oh dear um
could you theoretically engineer a virus
that can reproduce in human hosts
be transmissible but not do any harm
zero harm to a human
um no
actually it's funny i was having a
thought very much like this here's the
reason i say no
um you can do it so that they have
negligible harm but the very
nature of a virus is that it is going to
invade
cells and if it is going to invade cells
and take
over it is by definition taking those
cells
off of their regularly established job
yep
and very likely resulting in their
destruction because once those cells
start showing
foreign antigen they will be killed by
natural killer cells and then cytotoxic
t cells i believe um so the point is
loss of tissue is not good
right loss of tissue is bad if a virus
infecting a cell is part of what it does
is going to trigger
that then you're losing a little bit of
your capacity but it could be so little
that it's unmeasurable and in fact
this is at least part of what
a more traditional vaccine does right so
by giving you a neutralized virus
you can trigger immunity and that virus
infects cells so there are vaccines that
involve viruses that infect cells
and do a small enough amount of damage
to be worthwhile but
it's not zero yeah it's not zero and i
think i think the question was asked
specifically like
zero harm so good right as long as the
question is really about zero the answer
is no if that question
is negligible harm then yes almost
certainly
but it wouldn't well yes yes such a
virus could exist
but then there's a second layer of the
question which is could you
theoretically engineer such a virus do
we have that capacity
depends what you mean by engineer from
scratch definitely not right
uh could you modify a virus yes we do
something like that when we create
viruses out of live vaccine i mean
vaccines out of live viruses they're not
transmissible though
right right right so that's the that's
the key novel thing here
um and you know were you able to do that
you could in fact
undoubtedly this is what the person who
asked the question is thinking you could
create a transmissible vaccine
yep yeah yep so the last question is a
comment
and i think i know what the word means
but i don't know how to pronounce it
here's to viriditas
which actually means greenness lushness
veritas so it's not about veracity
which is a different root veritas
veriditas
veritas but this isn't that a game where
you throw green things
veritas i think it is yeah yeah it is
all right i think we've come to that
we have apparently come to a fizzling
end on this
dark horse podcast live stream what a
weird name what a
weird day it's been weird and you know
that animal that went behind that tree
has not emerged i can't believe it it
was a large critter
i am going to have to go look behind
that tree so that i can just assure
myself that it escaped while i wasn't
paying attention because otherwise
it's there it's there all right
and we are here but only for another
minute or so which point we are going to
go outside so we
uh want to remind you of a few things
uh we'll be back next week with episode
74 it's going to be a different
sort of a thing going on we're not going
to say anything more about that but it
is going to be different from
um our usual by a fair bit
uh for episode 74 so tune in then we
should have said that at the end of the
last hour
it didn't oh well um nothing to be done
nothing to be done
um let's see please consider joining us
at my patreon um tomorrow at 11 a.m
pacific we'll have our two hour private
q a
uh and we will um you know maybe get the
giggles or
be slightly just less distracted by
animals of color hiding behind trees um
yeah join brett his patreon you'll have
your first conversation of the month
before our next live stream right before
our next live stream
um yeah various various other truths
but uh maybe that's where we should stop
yep go outside winter is coming
the sun is shining some places like here
and i hope where you are
and uh i don't know be well
[Music]
you